following the San Bernardino attacks
fear-mongering has hit unforeseen levels
and aside from the rhetoric being
ignorant it's downright dangerous
for starters American Muslims are being
demonized this week Republican
frontrunner Donald Trump said he wants
to ban all Muslims from entering the
u.s. our country cannot be the victim of
horrendous attacks by people that
believe only in Jihad Trump may be the
loudest but he's certainly not the only
one maligning Muslims if there is a
cancer in Islam and if they're not gonna
learn to assimilate I don't want it in
this country more good people had
concealed carry permits then we could
end those Muslims before they before
they go up the hill we are living in
dangerous times ladies and gentlemen the
Jackals are at the door these are just
Fringe thoughts right maybe not a
November poll found that 56% of
Americans think that Islam is at odds
with American values which is leading to
what some Muslim American leaders say is
an uptick in hate crimes this week a
severed pig's head was left at a mosque
in Philadelphia and that follows death
threats vandalisms and shooting reports
at other American models a
representative from the Council on
american-islamic relations told CNN
after the backlash from the Paris
attacks I have never seen it like this
not even after 9/11 this inflammatory
rhetoric is playing into Isis's hands
many see the anti-muslim rhetoric as
counterproductive as it alienates
Muslims in the West exactly what Isis
wants in his oval office address this
week Obama said that this is not a war
on Islam and that is upsetting
conservatives in his entire remarks he
never once used the words radical
Islamic terrorism and the refusal to
call this for what it is a war on
radical Islam I would have used this
opportunity this speech to be able to
persuade people that were at war with
Islamic radical terrorism but according
to many including Hillary Clinton using
that term furthers
this is agenda by equating their actions
with an entire religion it helps to
create this Clash of Civilizations that
is actually a recruiting tool for Isis
and other radical jihadists even
President George W Bush avoided using
the term radical Islam and said days
after 9/11 that quote Islam is peace
finally this Isis heavy rhetoric is
ignoring another very pressing threat in
the u.s. gun violence so far in 2015
there have been more mass shootings than
dates but Congress still has yet to take
meaningful action to curb gun deaths
after the San Bernardino attacks the
Senate even rejected a measure that
would have stopped people on the
terrorist watch list from buying a gun
so when our leaders can't even curb
serious threats what will it take for
the national conversation to become
productive and less hateful